miios didn't really was dizzy in his
youth Genji Shimada lived a carefree and
self-indulgent life but when Genji
refused to join his older brother Hanzo
and running their clans vast criminal
empire
he was mercilessly cut down and left for
dead
bound by over watching given a new
cybernetic body Genji struggled with his
dual nature until the Omnicom
Sanada taught him to find inner peace
now in the Nexus Genji uses his elite
ninja skills to fight for what's right
Genji is an opportunistic mobile
assassin who can tear apart a weak
backline
jenji straight cyber agility allows him
to quickly traverse the battleground
when activated Ginji leaps into the air
and lands at his targeted location
jumping over any impassable terrain in
his path his first ability shuriken
launches a fan of three ninja stars in
the targeted direction this ability can
store up to three charges and its
cooldown refreshes all three charges at
once deflect is Ganges primary method of
self defense when activated he briefly
gains the protected status preventing
all damage to himself and dealing damage
to his nearest enemy whenever he is
attacked prioritizing heroes swift
strike serves as both a damage and
mobility tool Ginji dashes forward to
set distance damaging all enemies in his
path if an enemy hero dies soon after
being hit by swift strike its cooldown
is reset bindis first heroic ability
dragon blade worked similarly to how it
does in overwatch when activated he
draws his sword and gains a powerful
melee attack for a brief window of time
while dragon blade is active hitting Q
or R causes him to lunge forward and
swing his sword in a wide arc damaging
all enemies he hits
Eck's strike offers Ginji amour
front-loaded heroic option in terms of
damage he leaps into the air and carves
two giant slashes into the ground
damaging all enemies they hit he then
delivers a third and final attack as he
lands dealing heavy damage to all
enemies in the targeted area
gingy is that as best when using his
considerable mobility and deadly ninja
skills to burst down vulnerable
opponents cyber agility doubles as both
an engage and an escape talents that
enhance his trait grant additional
options for outmaneuvering the enemy
team even Genji's basic attacks most
impressive mobility after starting a
basic attack he can move while the
attack finishes allowing him to poke at
his enemies while dancing in and out of
their attack range
shuriken can deal a large amount of
damage if all three hit the same target
making it deadly at close range near
shuriken to Scout bushes and fog and
interrupt opponents who are channeling
objectives deflect works best against
heroes with rapid attacks like tracer
Orly means disintegrate minions and
structures can also trigger deflects
counter-attacks making it a powerful
offensive tool when diving into enemy
fortifications
use swift strike to finish off enemies
with low health so that its cooldown is
reset swift strike always travels a set
distance it can land you in a tough
situation if you're not careful when
fighting against dingy use stuns and
silences to interrupt deflect and
prevent him from escaping dragonblade is
particularly strong against isolated
enemies split lane pushers like gas lows
zagara or asthma Danner prime targets
when activating dragonblade the ability
lasts for some time so it can be used
for clearing waves if all nearby heroes
have been cut down before it ends
extract offers gedgie a powerful burst
damage option because he is involving ex
strike activating it when multiple
enemies are attacking you can help you
avoid the damage and quickly turn the
tide of battle the final explosion deals
more damage than the first two slashes
so make sure it connects
jenji is an Augmented cyborg ninja whose
agility and skill making an
exceptionally lethal threat make sure to
leave us a comment and subscribe to
heroes of the storm on YouTube and
around the web and we'll see you in the
Nexus you need a healing